Lawrence in New Jersey are on the bench
Pierre I shall go for it Lawrence hey
Ben I'm actually from South Jersey it's
the best are half the state so um anyway
um I have a question and actually a
classic movie recommendation for you
first so my question my question is what
lies at the far right end of the
American political spectrum I know the
left would have us believe that it's
fascism but you and I both know fascism
is barely right of communism and so my
question is would it be Anarchy so it
sort of depends on how you're describing
left and right and this is why yeah then
the differences between Europe and the
United States make a huge difference so
the left in America is correct that on
the far right of the European spectrum
is fascism because the far right of the
European spectrum is big government but
it is it is on behalf of a certain group
of people at the expense of another
group of people to protect homeland to
protect culture and and that is done in
opposition to communism right this is
why the Nazis
it is correct to describe them as a
right-wing group in Germany it would be
very incorrect to describe them as a
right-wing group in America because
American right and left a very different
American right and left is about the
size and scope of government there's
broad agreement in Europe about the size
and scope of government the question is
to whom it should appeal on the on the
in the United States the the argument
really is about what the government
ought to do in the first place the left
is sort of the European right and left
is the left in America and then on the
right in America is as you move ever
further to the right you end up in sort
of libertarian categories and so Anarchy
would probably be on the very far right
of the spectrum but again it's a
different spectrum and so we have to be
exact about the language we're using and
whether we're using European standards
or whether we are using American
standards of right and left and I think
people like to mix this stuff up all the
time so you'll see people historians say
well how could these conservatives in
America claim that the Nazis were a
left-wing group by American standards
they were left-wing group they purported
to want nationalized health care they
wanted the government to be deeply
involved in every aspect of Industry
they wanted the government to to make
sure that the people were taken care of
on a wide variety of topics there were
certainly not small government Prima
free-market capitalists
right we would be the definition of
right-wing in the United States so the
attempts to sort of conflate those two
is something left in the United States
likes to do so you're right that that to
describe the Nazi
or fascism as a right-wing construct in
the United States is a weird sort of
thing to do but again it depends on on
which spectrum you're using Lawrence
really appreciate the call Jessica in
Atlanta you're on the bench bo sure I'll
go for it Jessica hey Ben love your show
two things real quick I just want to
thank you and the Daily wire for
responsibly reporting on covin 19 I
think as someone who works on public
health it really means a lot to me when
media outlets report health crises with
care unlike the mainstream media you
guys don't blow things out of proportion
to drum up viewership so it's greatly
appreciated well I really appreciate
that blue that I always believe that you
know especially when this kind of stuff
happens people want information first
and then political takes exactly exactly
so that being said the way China has
handled things have been admittedly
terrible yes between shutting down early
reports of the virus and not cooperating
with us it almost feels like they've
gone out of their way to make things as
hard as possible
so how does China's an delaying of Cova
19 not demonstrate to the American
people just out that commie and as an ad
I mean they absolutely should it
absolutely should I mean but
unfortunately what what you see from the
media is that what is gonna be needed is
some sort of great repression and so
people think okay well government
repression forced quarantine you know be
really great at that communist countries
right so you saw the media in the early
days this thing celebrate how China was
locking it down right before they got to
oh yeah also trying to let the cat out
of the bag and let this thing spread
because they didn't want the shame of
having it blamed on China and they were
killing officials or imprisoning
officials were talking about it before
they started reporting on that it was
look what a great job China is doing and
shutting down all of Lu Han I mean can
you imagine in the United States can you
shut down a city of 13 million people
obviously not China is really handling
this thing so the the sort of fascist
top-down control that was exerted in
China was seen as a feature not a bug of
the system the problem is that you know
originally it comes with non
transparency it comes with crappy public
health facilities it comes with higher
death rates so it should be a ringing
rebuke of Chinese communism but the
truth is that you see how the media
cover things right now and that is that
if there's any shortcoming in terms of
the transmission of kovat 19 then they
immediately blame the government as
though bigger government would fix this
thing well you know the government can
really only do what the government can
do
the government isn't God the government
can't prevent one person from
transmitting copa90 and to another
person all the government can really do
is prevent travel at the initial stages
and then make sure the public health
agencies have the resources that they
need in order to in order to move
forward with it and the government's
doing all that it can but to suggest
that China handled this thing well let's
put it this way if there were an
outbreak of a disease in the United
States or in the West it would it be
handled much more quickly and much more
seriously and what's much and with much
more transparency than it was in China
in the first place and then you would
have an increasing drive for for a
government intervention ISM the nice
thing about about a free system and
democratic system is that there are
gradations of government control that
can be gradually accessed as the threat
grows there are no gradations in China
it's either you got to move around or
you don't get to move around and go home
and we're gonna lock you in your house
we're gonna weld you in so that it
should be Iranian rebuked of China
arable no it definitely should and I
wonder if this is not some small
reflection and why Joe Biden has bunch
up in the polls because people see
what's going on and they're like oh no
we can't have a Bernie Sanders well I
mean I think that I think that it
definitely has to do with all these
things coronavirus just no one has faith
in Bernie to run the system because why
would you have faith in a 78 year old
communist who has never done a useful
thing in his life was on welfare when he
was running for mayor of Burlington and
who lived his entire life until the age
of 39 without holding down a regular job
do I trust that guy to protect me from
Corona boy I don't protect that I don't
trust that guy to handle make a nice cup
of coffee I don't trust him to do a
o'seas old bartending job let alone
handling the country that's Iike really
appreciate the call clay in Minnesota
you're in Ben Shapiro show go for clay
hey yes sir hey Ben I'm a fan of the
show and so I'm a physician at a major
medical institution and with all the
awesome Bernie Sanders talking about
health care is a human right I just
wanted to get your take on a couple of
things one when he says you know people
have a human right to healthcare what
amount of health care do you think he's
just you know actually ending like so
should every patient has the ability to
go to Hopkins or Mayo will stand for a
thirst is just a physician an MP or a PA
or a nurse and if they do have that
right you know to think that the
patient's actually do have a human right
to the services of physicians who
sometimes are abusive to the to the
medical system or to the
to the position itself yeah clay this is
the question that I've had over and over
and over is that there have to be some
logical limits to that after ninety nine
years old and you have prostate cancer
is the idea that your health human right
now mandates the government expended
ollars on your prostate health care for
experimental drugs like what exactly
does this mean and the answer is that
Bernie has no answer to this because in
the end he means that he's gonna make
the decisions right he means that he and
his egl Emmanuel are gonna make the
decisions as to the level of care
necessary also simply declaring
something a right does not make it
appear magically South Africa in its
constitution as a right to housing has a
right to employment has a right to
healthcare nobody has a job nobody has
health care nobody has a house in South
Africa scope just saying things our
rights do not make the rights magically
appear the only rights that are self
effectuating are the rights that do not
require something of somebody else and
this is why then the left declares a
positive right what they really mean is
that they're going to force somebody
else to comply with your will a right to
health care means in the end that some
form of compulsion is going to have to
be undertaken whether it is government
ownership of the health care system or
cramdown reimbursement rates or bringing
in people from abroad to fill these
roles in order to provide the health
care that they think is necessary and
again it's not the health care you think
it's necessary to the health care that
they think is necessary that's why even
if you want to say that health care is a
human right you have to determine
exactly what the hell you're talking
about are you talking about a Singapore
system where everybody is forced to pay
into a very basic minimum of the system
but then you get to elevate your
spending based on the level of health
care you want which is sort of like both
both Switzerland and Singapore or do you
mean a full-on National Health Service
like Great Britain where a right to
health care means that you may be
waiting in line for a year for a hip
surgery and you may have to give birth
in a toilet like it there's a wide
variety of ways that such a quote
unquote right materializes clay it's a
good point really appreciate the call
we'll be taking more of your calls at
eight five five two thirty six thirty
two twenty eight again that's eight five
five two three six thirty two twenty
eight on Super Tuesday this is the bench
Bureau show